ils sont mille sept cents affectés au
programme cseries au québec à mirabel
notamment 1700 travailleurs qui peuvent
pousser un soupir de soulagement
south bank ça va devrait être positif
avant ça sortait de la cseries dans ce
moment on voit le personnel de retour
aura-t-on series on est proche où joyce
à bout certes on partage des risques
c'est pour préserver des emplois bien
rémunérés que québec a décidé de devenir
le partenaire de bombardier en créant
une co entreprise une société qui va
récupérer les activités du programme
cseries ses employés mais aussi les
risques liés à une initiative qui bat de
l aile
le ministre de l'économie estime que le
jeu en vaut la chandelle est ce qu'on a
besoin chez bombardier chez de
liquidités ou nous comme gouvernement
considère que c'est la chose à 20 je
vous retourne la question madame
qu'est-ce-qu'il plus qu'il le fait pour
le faire on parle de 40 mais l'emploi
cela dit bombardier a dû libérer le
programme cseries d'une partie de sa
dette est radié 3 milliards 200 millions
de dollars de sorte que la société en
commandite eu et écrire le cseries est
une société et épurée de ce fardeau love
un fardeau qui retombe sur les épaules
de bombardier qui affiche une perte de
près de 5 milliards de dollars au
troisième trimestre et qui doit annuler
son programme d'avions learjet le pdg
l'admet l'entreprise en l1 parce qu'elle
a vu trop grand bombardier avait pris
plusieurs fera g en parallèle pour un
agrès l'organisation de 20 milliards de
dollars c'était énorme
québec devra emprunter pour financer le
programme cseries en période de
restrictions budgétaires
dans le contexte actuel mais je peux
vous dire une chose le gouvernement a
réussi à trouver de l'argent en approche
de gauche.le j'espère que pour le front
commun où on a trouvé une approche de
droite
selon cet analyste l'aide
gouvernementale vient colmater une
brèche
ça va régler le problème le plus urgent
c'est à dire le manque de liquidités
par contre ça ne règle pas le problème
de fond le problème de fond suivante
cseries
le pdg de bombardier soutient que des
acheteurs potentiels se sont manifestés
n'empêche la dernière commande de six 6
remonte à plus d'un an ici maxime
bertrand radio canada montréal